drill challenge
us from sarah black by actor board
with a 12 month mind' percent of
fortune 500 companies
board members of blush om sera
then becomes online percent of fortune 500
companies
board member at black sixty-six percent
of fortune 500 board members and white
a 10% of fortune of a word members
of white women
statistically seventy-two person of
directors have previously board
experience and have been stirring or I
seriously hear
hi busy and strobl so my person a
board member so important fortune father
and company sixty-six  persons white my
ne 10 persons white women mariette say
but this the right it's interesting
joint you have the press and the blog
population in marcus 13 point for fit
so these large presented their that
there is not a great in groups de
brands yoga my percent de  fortune 500
including phi phi companies and wind
mini location na wi-fi throughout your
readers limiter
business week kriopigi he was in
owen ju  st my my my life and baby while
a low fat in thunder jaw creators and
week rode and indes more in the camber is
a fresh throw whiskey camping weena and
mrna your blog minus 1 is that already in need he
coach board in the yummy in the student
front at a multicultural board and
summer but how the war natural stones
are in in order
yes i ken said negan does is your graduate degree
never in icann cells so and who more
take charge and go and can't show i become a
control in english  misbeek al
thousands getstring de not major just
bij this is a garden de charles white
house des als greater businesses to
describe the next fortune 500 barely is
anyway i a pro freud ar boards in
alaska not i him in it what each
that's why podcast like this  is why the
information and the awareness in
tigi bad he zinc copper american you can make
all kinds of beds with your lume cube
monte carlo guys here gets local is the
green screen a company that a rancher
here oh [ __ ]
they would go  but for business why
moody's i bought a new hope
instinct surely just how i'm an icy
online person also for survival drill
numbers it's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what
i'm in my heart
maar die realize dots jumpy conclusion
jacket
starting block in it and numbers  with rapper
grtz the
14% american is black ok
seven types and latinos 16 wordpress and
my fire foundation
apply multi-cultural matti breschel
eyelashes and in that in a drawer of
sing along filippino people know whether
the rising so die are on so thin reels
instinct chili  white wood stick julia
girlfriend
start directing better to get mine
and see what i need to release for
percent per minutes
at least more is in the population such a
tube pleasure
number one for hiring the best person for
just to target price i will  other
talk to build biden kind of pigeon
holding self worth i'm going to select
in blaak female ok
discusses millions and kubota what
is the best person out there for the job
social confli  cten that way the hard
best percy village but it's a
tram and paul forgive that bush
she so the way shuttle de in
was last again in my process the african
americans for on the edge of 500
fortune pond cambrium show and
musical was  5% and him shirt around five
o'clock ziggo was super set
so sonic do better and the book is
for that in a club society so house
it's quiet the best person for the job
shy shy guy and baby free yes what's there
also very good  kibbutz put on and nice
d d ok ah did for use by day before
you mind stijn becomes paws week soc and
on which you but here's my de he
uses
online and ipad to fall to percent
will percent chica this word processor
american by african american legion
starting  point for percent
wordpress and azure latinos aging point
5% and and what pers and edgar wright
population wires ready for the two
million african americans and american
so roughly fifty 2 million hispanics and
the black  tournament' by the four
million
white zo lets do white and black
specifically cosmonaut often in hispanic
shows her story to read or die for
million white in america
for the one million bankrupt million
bikes in america ok
light black tracking population spinning
demon out pull up today  day of this but
de goverment en cis that idea that god is
6 degrees confirmed by race en ethnic
die if the check this method is also so
pathetic projection and you or a
bachelor's degree for white for white
press and it was fresh is blacks
what degree becomes  percent i get the great
white tutor population in america oh oh
white one point you one million is the
tigi color she created during that
you're all black swallow night the two
towns and ok for that specific academic
year zo weiss weiss weiss news x plus
times more barbie latino's get my
bachelor degree and african americans
latino's was 207 10.000 eur south
african americans a hanger in my the
two towns and which is not  a big deal
week is the poor latino students
spanish and african him and and so brave
mix it through the asia numbers association
numbers or after while songs writer
hello rita rita them as your loon and
latinos and and pee both partners to is
one too  long to the sea
yes shell and will cues warm could be
sanding belt notice if you wanna be in the
farmer all fortune 500 companies the
moss board member at a room
things that grow and that must have fancy
scrolls the experience
and to anne fortune faber a  hijack
boron and aaron have for you that growth
and ona beauty creek so in the house already so
late you push it highly qualified people
they go and get the great if you wanna
be on a board had her qualified
person guyane border hurry
how have the rider  china
sits on a chair me to the farmer dry your
eyes chairman of the board of the field
guide you guys getting married robot
china choose and sales point for tight
and chic a colleague universe s  hipping
decorate you with a chic is you
will be there publishing play pro
single white scholarships air max
skyline
wasjes category of university press
and cheese headlight
cap black and see the chairman of the
board who would you put him on black single
mother you know what he said  the great
that brings value who shoots the chairman
at pierced tail stanley
bari think these numbers arab [ __ ]
and so forth up to be cautious
by ten pounds for person who had
13 point for person did the board
members my blog you can say that  this
can be the people pme based on how many
arm thing decrease therefore caring for
will it snatchers taba more faithful juno and
aroma fish has safari camp you what
seaweed discriminates
why i discriminate moblike word
zucchini and a hope it's people who
just me it simply discrimination
market share your e60 android apps by
piano black stone white here strings but
that there and come to buy a new one
person  million dollars in gallery
seniorweb
everything a views in many circumstances
and you agree
nike air to have blog board member such a
derby closet door product in finnish the
projector athletes nfl and binet s
jep that's nothing to sport aelse have two
or business I go to  de kering
wonders sugar are expressions that so
newest get canio westeinde
ryuk libertair nfi by jackie nice to be
otherwise wel ernie spiral him indeed
this so not wie sam cleaning up to do
what i don't think it's a crazy en
esther nam kree oh my  gosh americans
a race is nation demo now blackboard
mumbai by your it there on your scarce
cambodia dark blue skies degryse action
phone ideally scholes
der board members starvation i break
carlos i know if i need extra see
texas one and verses haven is there before
said danny  plug and of the stab that prince
anesthesia of a company she texas company
signs of texas university more stable
salad pride and texas do and texas
university more stable some delicious
priva  too akoe
for the same try the world us on
ustream and jona lewie a farmer have
a meeting together all the primary
care and our deal with the aller hi billy
holiday but he already walked with a golden
ticket is the right code juliet i get
family that growth  you can have coffee at
both kingdom do us we primary
key qatar of ivy you make up to date and
million are you and country garden and
nutrition
yes those more videos but if you want to
say thank you to all something difficult with
glenn the community  gala just he must
nowadays a minute local
and here I have letters and
fallopian tubes I get it
after which I meet my savior acceptance
for jc' to your new device ikea and
ios celebration time from your my
arm acceptance of critics who then so'  n
everything aqua city clock samesh uniqueaas
m.sc baren frame you it citigroup
citigroup snow finance or waste
ceo at big wall street bike boots quick
guide city and earth day that's maseo
michael cor  baby care after you can you
dead sea seo he'll be replaced by jane
freezer
ruci door scope cam florence gone
louis awake note if you want to thank
you for old men for larger becomes
mckinsey is that the consulting group
the big is what so she  has pedigree
en cicek Lekker zo scheffer this moment
no frazier is a certified jeee and
this is this is normal story by the way
the magic of the major banks american
this is the first female see you ever
ever of a major wall street am no
fear of  so it's a tough chain
chat xd and wonderful
romanov problem and radars and johanna
offender 1 yes die your app that there 6 itenc if
they would be entrepreneur and i wanna
be in the business rode no so i'll
see days after marie c some  cio's
and major best technology jane oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh no
the family already in the form there in
hertfordshire youtube and then yes yes it
will be difficult and it is here
armor die so study 2016 percent of all
of  work in sh  it this incident showroom
in 2001 yes as do seminars december
by phone and guys i wish my oh my god
me so my what cuff in it him in
my 10th level from 2005 what will be
tomorrow with the upgrade swing house in am
high possible terror in politics
mormont  there is an api for private
organizations housing
sector director or fabrizio she
camper what the siphon nlp living in lübeck
breaking google boy circle and her round
houses in simplon mushrooms with his
and mill pi start in the us and jerry
training camp season your garden jennefer
bad beautiful  flat in the clowns who who do you
surf in a group with jordi and the room
party and
kitchen table compositions is up to the
people go together my house my best
released a merry
row hmm i think i see decisions try
it secretly in your wife scio
gill operation  in pajama party yes you
why not share of a chairwoman
what george rr martin certified she's
so it in on the reader kinder old t
partly ah i'm very surprised is so the
first o  m a share and very surprised
bij de fack baby pillow wim bosman get a
decrease we myngle
gadget ede die een earwig intake
education research die sam supplies
partner taking place i had my graduation
student chara to care for doing what she
knows
[Music]